vous dites que il fallait lisser
repasser les liasses de billets parce
que froisser elle rentrait pas dans le
coffre quand même hein
ce soir Hubert book of za bonsoir
alors
Hubert ou comme ça au début des années
80 vous devenez le propriétaire de la
célèbre boîte de nuit les Bains Douches
et là en quelques années le petit juif
tunisien parti de rien va devenir
l'empereur international de la fête
pendant des années les stars d'Hollywood
vont se succéder dans votre boîte de
nuit vous gagnez des fortunes hélas dans
cet océan d'argent d'alcool et de
cocaïne vous perdez le contrôle c'est la
chute c'est l'enfer votre ami Jean-Luc
Delarue en Moura vous presque votre
histoire vous la racontez dans un livre
coécrit avec Jean-François kervean et
intitulé 10000 et une nuits publiées
chez Robert Laffont et à 20h dans un
lieu éternel
[Musique]
Hubert book of ZAR bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes nuls
1950 à Tunis père businessman à la
petite semaine et votre mère artiste
peintre sublime sublime alors quand
votre père met les voiles vous avez deux
ans
mais le pire sera l'ostracisme dont
votre mère sera victime parce que c'est
vrai qu'une femme seule avec des enfants
dans les années 50 en Tunisie c'est pas
évident et cette honte de l'exclusion
vous la connaîtrez également
au pensionnat de Marseille où on vous
met avec votre frère
vous dites Hubert depuis j'ai besoin
qu'on m'aime
oui j'ai même avant j'avais besoin mais
c'est ça c'est-à-dire que en même temps
par la suite je savais que ma mère
m'aimait franchement profondément
mais bon on a été séparé pendant toute
notre enfance et on s'est retrouvé qu'à
Paris à l'âge de 14 ans elle a un
nouveau mec et là vous vous tombez
amoureux en allant au lycée d'une
prostituée de 32 ans qui est dans un
dans un bar et vous vivez avec elle dans
un hôtel à ce moment-là si oui c'était
une façon de défier ma maman et de
vouloir faire le malin alors vous
épousez Sylvette
une polonaise de bonne famille ouais
voilà j'ai voulu me ouais calmer le jeu
là vous vous lancez dans l'immobilier
vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent très très
vite tir à un moment vous donne un
programme avec 50 appartements à vendre
et vous avez une technique d'enfer vous
dites le mec écouter là je m'en vais
j'ai tout vendu non mais j'avais appris
ça au poker oui alors justement vous
jouez au poker et c'est en jouant au
poker que vous gagnez une pizzeria dans
le quartier de la Huchette et alors là
vous vous dites en fait ce qui marche
dans le quartier c'est pas tellement les
pizzerias c'est les Grecs en une semaine
je ferme et je fais le plus beau grec du
quartier et ça cartonné alors à 30 ans
vous vous retrouvez avec le nabab du
quartier parce que vous achetez tous les
restaurants de la rue Saint-Séverin de
la Huchette alors vous dites à l'époque
c'est comme une caricature de pieds-noir
quoi absolument ouais j'ai même acheté
la Porsche Targa oui alors en 1984 vous
achetez les Bains Douches qui à l'époque
et la boîte la plus branchée de Paris
c'est hasard je te bien copain avec un
certain Jonathan oui Jonathan
et c'est là où je
tu devrais aller voir une affaire rue du
bourlabé qui est bains douches et voilà
c'était la boîte marché moins bien mais
c'était quand même la boîte la plus
branchée de Paris à l'époque et là vous
commencez à cette époque-là apprendre de
la cocaïne
proposé oui à 34 ans qu'elle avait
jamais pris une ligne alors là vous êtes
très malin vous récupérez geekuevas le
10 jockey du palace Sylvie grimbach qui
était relation publique du palace
Jonathan Amar qui était déjà avec vous
et vous engagez Claude chal qui est un
grand professionnel du night clubbing et
là la boîte marche au-delà de toutes vos
espérances on pouvait avoir ce mail qui
peut être on pouvait avoir aussi bien
des rockstars que des travailleurs
et en même temps à minuit arriver trois
princesses alors blond qui sortent voilà
alors ça marche très bien dans un
premier temps on voit Mick Jagger
Jean-Baptiste mondinot Karl Lagerfeld
Thierry Mugler Christian Lacroix David
Bowie tout le monde est là et bientôt
grâce à votre amitié avec le producteur
américain Arnold mille Chan
c'est plus le tout pareil qu'on voit
chez vous mais le tout Hollywood Michael
Douglas Al Pacino Stallone De Niro
Nicholson DiCaprio Johnny Depp Kevin
Spacey enfin il y a aucune boîte à Paris
qui a eu un tel casting ça n'est jamais
c'est jamais arrivé alors là vous gagnez
un fric monstre vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
il y a des jours vous dites que il
fallait lisser repasser les liasses de
billets parce que froisser elle rentrait
pas dans le coffre quand même mais j'ai
le plaisir coffre
et c'est là donc que je vous rencontre
et je fais dans votre boîte de nuit les
Bains Douches ma première émission qui
s'appelle dan minuit et un jour vous
êtes arrêté vous vous retrouvez en
prison à Fresnes en fait l'histoire
c'est que vous achetiez les bouteilles
de vodka 7 euros et vous les vendiez 260
euros Hubert franchement
vous marchez 35 fois là mais comment je
peux remplir mes coffres sinon
et là donc la tôle c'est dur là non
écoutez pour moi
rétrospectivement ça fait partie de la
légende ouais alors dès que vous sortez
de la prison de Fresnes votre chauffeur
vous attend avec la Mercedes il a
préparé deux lignes de coke sur la
coudoir une nouvelle une chemise propre
une chemise propre et un short 24 et
tout recommence
vous investissez dans la nuit parisienne
vous rachetez le Palace à cette époque
là et vous voulez ouvrir des Bains
Douches dans le monde entier à New York
allons partout mais alors faut dire
quand même les choses vous êtes
tellement défoncé à l'époque que vous ne
voyez pas le monde changer Hubert
c'était moi festif voilà moi festif
c'est ça
et c'est là que vous rencontrez Jean-Luc
Delarue alors comment avec Jean-Luc une
vraie histoire d'amour faite de Petrus
d'escort-girls et de cocaïne
il y a un jour il y en a 40 quand même
à vos carburez à l'époque quand même à 3
4 g de côtes par jour
bon et Jean-Luc et moi c'est vrai que il
a faisait chauffer l'autre quoi vous
entraîniez mutuellement malheureusement
pas pour les Jeux Olympiques voilà
et là alors vous êtes potes avec de la
rue avec Robert De Niro et vous montez
tous les trois des restaurants à Paris
mais vous excite vous font perdre le
contrôle de vos affaires
j'ai perdu la notion la notion du réel
du
alors que avant j'étais le bon petit
juste tunisien qui savait que il fallait
acheter quelque chose à 10 et 20 graçons
et je répondais à 10 alors les restos
font faillite ça vous coûte à vous 5
millions d'euros et ça coûte aussi à
Jean-Luc Delarue 5 millions d'euros les
Bains meurent doucement
alors vous achetez un restaurant et un
bar à ce moment-là à Ibiza mais là quand
même vous êtes à 5 g par jour
vous pesez 130 kg et alors comme vous
bougez plus de chez vous peut-être assis
sur le balcon en train de regarder la
mer en les employés qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils piquent dans la caisse bah oui
voilà il pique dans la caisse
que je vais faire comme beau enfin bon
voilà c'était là vous êtes carrément
carrément à l'eau
j'avais perdu à peu près 25 ou 30 et je
les ai foutu dans la flèche d'Ibiza vous
faites peur à l'époque je me voyais pas
c'est inquiétant j'ai pas eu assez de
gens qui m'ont
un jour votre fille vient vous récupérer
elle vous emmène à l'hosto à Paris
comment respiratoire
aujourd'hui ça fait 5 ans que vous
n'avez pas pris de drogue vous vivez des
économies que vous avez réalisées quand
vous avez vendu vos affaires à
Ibiza
mais en même temps je me sens bien
je suis personnellement aujourd'hui je
suis plus heureux qu'à l'époque parce
que déjà je suis beaucoup plus conscient
je réalise plus les choses et j'ai mes
deux enfants qui me qui m'offrent des
des plaisirs incroyable c'est formidable
c'est ça un destin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
faut dire quand même une chose
méfiez-vous de la cocaïne c'est pas
juste une drogue récréative c'est une
drogue qui au bout d'un moment vous
mange la myéline du cerveau c'est à dire
la substance qui entoure les neurones
donc je ne vous conseille pas d'en
prendre voilà et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu